Little kids should be doing whatever
they can that's productive and useful as
young as they can.
Like if you have a two year old is just
toddling around,
you know you can get that two year old
to set the table.
We used to have our kids do that.
It's really funny to watch it because
the table's like half above their heads.
So you know,
you give the two year old and knife,
not a sharp one.
Obvious.
That's a different cycle.
I can save that for next time.
Peterson.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know when you say,
okay,
go put this on the table now they can't
exactly put it beside the plate because
they can't see the damn plate,
but the kids are actually.
If you're careful with them and you,
you adjust your expectations to their
level of developing expertise.
That's called the zone of proximal
development.
By the way there they're more than happy
to,
to comply because it helps them develop
and move forward and they have a really
powerful instinct for them,
you know?
And with kids,
it's also interesting if you,
if you watch them very carefully,
you can see when they're ready for the
next task,
you know,
and then also the kids,
people talk a lot about self esteem,
which is very badly conceptualized self
esteem because it,
it'll come to me and you should feel
good about yourself,
which I don't believe.
I think you should feel good about who
you,
who you could be if you've got your act
together and you shouldn't be feeling so
good about who you are now and your
story state.
It's like,
what the hell,
man,
you're 17.
Don't be feeling too good about
yourself.
Get the hell.
Get your act together and see what you
could be and feel good about your
trajectory.
That's way different,
but also your competence.
And so like even with little kids is
they know they're being taken care of.
They have an existential debt to their
parents is like if you allow them to be
useful and encourage them to do things,
then they get to pay off that
existential debt and then they can see
that they're contributing members of
even this small society and it's no lie.